that's because even though people like
you who are young and healthy will
probably not get sick from this this is
really not something not scary for you
there are people who could potentially
become sick right and so we're talking
about people who are older or people who
are already sick with other types of
things like someone who might have
cancer and is on special kinds of
medicines their immune systems are kind
of like not really working great and so
the reason why we're not going to places
where there are lots of people that
could gather on an inside is to make
sure we're not spreading the disease to
people the virus to people who could get
really sick from it so people who don't
have very good immune systems right now
and so we're we're actually doing this
so that we can protect the people around
us and I think that's a really important
thing for humans to do is to protect
each other
right and that's one of the ways that
we're doing it and it also helps our
hospitals by making sure that people are
reducing the amount of exposure to other
people
it'll help our hospitals be able to
handle taking care of the people who are
actually sick from this and so we're
we're helping doctors and we're helping
nurses and we're helping health care
professionals by making sure that they
are not going to be like bombarded with
patients so it's really important that
we do this and it's hard it's hard not
to be with our friends but it's one of
the biggest helpers that we can do in in
our community